his heart To the Quran and the
and the light of Allah and the
light of Iman.
This is a very important issue.
The light of Iman, the light of
faith.
hope, reason These things to be
brought out in us He seeds of
hope and reason and faith and
belief and reliance upon Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala This is the
greatest gift that a person, a
human being can have. A greater
gift that a person can be
given. There's no money they
can buy it. There's no amount
of wealth that can compensate
it. There's no way that a
person can ever be given a gift
greater than that. After the
gift of having a sound mind and
being guided to the religion of
Islam.
We live in a time where our
scales are skewed.
[Silence]
As you know, Dunya, buenas in a
Quran.
[Silence]
The way that we see what is
good and what is bad. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said
the good and the evil Whether
that be good deeds or evil
deeds, or the people of those
deeds.
good and evil decent and
indecent, right and wrong, just
and unjust. They will never be
the same. They are not equal
with Allah. And his court and
his judgement is the only
relevant judgment. He said and
that is even if you are
astounded by the magnificence
or the seeming magnificence of
Of the the evil. It will never
be the same. We've mentioned
before the narration of Muslim.
It's a well-known narration but
it continues to go back to this
concept and that is
This religion began in the time
of the prophet with him and
then Khadijah and then who was
the next person that believed
in him?
Prophet then he went back to
Khadijah. She believed in him.
And then who believed in him
after that?
huh.
Yes, her uncle. Ma'am.
And then after that, Abu Bakr
and Ali bin Abhita Alib and
there was a time when there was
the whole Ummah was only six or
seven people. people, even
people who loved him. All
everybody loved him. They loved
him because he wasn't decisive
at that point. But religion is
decisive. That's its nature.
That Allah tells us that all of
the people were one nation. And
then Allah sent down the
prophets and the books and
people were divided. That's the
nature of of religion. we can
all agree when it comes times
to truth and falsehood and
right and wrong, people
disagree. and so sometimes we
get caught up in this idea that
we need to just gather everyone
on one heart. It can't work
that way. The prophets and
messengers came to gather
people on one on one religion.
and let those who decide to
follow by the wayside fall by
the wayside We don't want them
to. We don't push them away.
We're not we're not bad to
them. We don't try to push them
away but people will eventually
choose wrong. and there will be
conflict. This is the nature of
religion As religion comes and
it's intrusive and it says,
this is right and this is
wrong. This is halal. This is
haram. This is false and this
is true. What will happen?
People will become divided.
right? That's the nature of of
of religion. and so, point here
is that Islam began as a
strange thing. It was very
strange. Is it four, five
people, six people Yeah,
they're good people. They're
upstanding people but now all
of a sudden, they're telling us
you know, all of what your
forefathers are doing are
incorrect. The worship of idols
is wrong. these idols hold
no value with Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala. Riba is haram.
alcohol is haram. Yeah, but it
makes us feel good. Yeah, but
it makes us rich. Gambling is
haram. Yes, but it makes us
feel lucky and rich. And So,
people were divided and this
was something very strange. Why
rock the boat? Leave it it
is. We're all happy. We're
living in Mecca. Everybody's
fine. Why do you have to bring
this up? right? This is the
this was the the the beginnings
of Islam And so at one point,
Islam and the Muslims were the
minority. and so, We live in a
time where Islam is starting
and is returning to being
strange even amongst its own
people. Even amongst amongst
his own claimants. Those who
claim those who claim
dissension from Islam or those
who claim that they are are
part of Islam or refer to
themselves as Muslims and we
are the Muslims etcetera. Much
of the prophet much of the
Quran itself is very strange to
them. Give us haven't read the
Quran. If we have, we haven't
understood it. We haven't taken
it. We haven't understood it
the way the prophet did. The
sunnah itself is very strange.
And when you implement these
strange things, you become a
stranger even amongst your own
family. Even in your own
household. even in your own, in
your own society, of people who
are Muslim. And fingers are
pointed at you. Why rock the
boat? We're all fine. Let
everybody just, no, it can't be
that. There has to be we
were not created to all get
along. We were created to
worship Allah alone without any
partners. And we love and hate
we take allegiances and
alliances based on our belief
in Allah in the last day.
That's where we draw our line
in the sand. So this now in our
times very strange. Why is it
such a big deal? Right? So even
issues that go to the heart of
our religion. That will
literally if they are allowed
to be unfettered and unbridled
will destroy our religion as we
know it. A hacks on the Quran.
By the by Muslims, people claim
to be Muslim. Attacks on the of
the prophet attacks on Bukhari,
Sahih Muslim, attacks on the
book of the the books of
attacks on the beliefs of the
Muslims. Right? Many things.
Many things, even things with
regards to belief in Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Does Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
have actions or not? Does Allah
love and can he be loved or
not? These are things that
people of innovation have
brought up. And they've said
no. Musa never was spoken to by
Allah. And Ibrahim was never
taken as a close friend and
loved by Allah. And the human
being cannot be loved by Allah
and the human being cannot love
Allah. Yes, these are things
that are said. And the Quran is
created and the Quran is not
actually the words of Allah and
so on and so forth. And then
people come and they spew this
this madness and this venom and
then people put in their
comments. Oh, why is it such a
big deal? Why are people
dividing each other? It's not a
big deal. So, what? You believe
Allah is this or like
this? Who cares? We're all
Muslim. No, it can't be like
that. If we, if the scholars of
Islam allow things to get out
of control that, the
Muslim was, the Muslim Ummah
will self destruct which is
what it's doing right now. and
so, a stand has to be taken
Why? For the preservation of
our religion There has to be
men and women who stand in
spite of the fingers pointed at
him. As Allah said,
they are not hindered and they
do not fear the blame and
reproach of those who blame
them because they know they're
in the right.
Allah said to the prophet rely
on Allah, you are definitely
upon the clear truth. Now, I'm
not speaking about issues of
minutia and filk. This is
something that even the
companions differed on and this
is not an issue. Should I put
my hands here or here or up
here or this is this is not
what we're speaking about.
We're we're speaking about the
core of our religion. Right?
What does it represent? Not
just that it is the pillar of
of the prophet if you topple
the temple of Al Bukhari, there
is no because all of the relies
on that book. That book is the
basis. It's the strongest book
that we have. Which most
meticulously documents the
words of the prophet in
revelation. Every other book
revolves around that book of of
with regards to the sunnah. but
if we open it up and we allow
it to be debated, things that
for 1, 300 1, 400 years, the
Muslims have always, the, the
mainstream Muslims have said,
Al Bukhari is beyond reproach.
And then now, we open the
floodgates and people start to
say, well, maybe it's not such
a good book. Maybe we don't
have to follow it. Maybe it's
this, maybe it's that. What
comes after Sahih Al Bukhari?
The Quran
That's how it will go. So,
there has to be men and women
that will take a stand on these
issues. Things that go to the
crux of our belief. Such as,
does Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
interact with his servant in
real time? This is the belief
of the Muslims. Right? Some of
the Tabereen, they used to say,
I can see the displeasure of
Allah for an action that I have
committed, that a sin that I
have committed, and how my
animal acts with me, and how my
wife talks to me. They can see
the, the, the, the way that
their animal is being unru and
maybe their family at home is
being unruly and they can say,
yes, this is because of a sin
I've committed and and this is
a stress that's being placed
upon me. What does this mean?
This means that Allah interacts
with us directly. But if we
open the floodgates to say, no,
Allah doesn't interact with you
directly. Which is what's been
said and what's been pushed.
It's been said that Allah does
not become angry with a person
and then be pleased with the
person based on their actions
in real time. It only matters
at the end. What they end up to
be. You know what that means?
That means that when Omar Abdul
Khattab was killing the Muslims
when when Khaled Ibn Al Waleed
was slaughtering the Muslims
and attempting to kill the
prophet Allah was always
pleased with him. Cuz he was
going to end up being Muslim.
Does that make sense? and then
people say, well, what does
that have to do with my normal
life? The anger of Allah has
ramifications in this life and
in the hereafter. If Allah is
unpleased with you right now,
you will feel it in your life
now. It'll start in your heart
and it will and it will fluster
around and that which goes on
around you. And the opposite is
true. If Allah is pleased with
you now, you will feel it in
your heart and it will manifest
itself around you. Allah's
anger and Allah's pleasure have
ramifications in real time now.
But the point is, is that these
things have been taken lightly
because back to what we started
with and that is we have
different scales that we see
the world with now. We've been
inoculated. We've been we've
been,
reprogrammed to see the world
in a different way. So now, if
a person has a lot of money and
is very wealthy, all of the
sudden, whatever they say is
gold. It should be written down
in gold and followed. As if
it's a religion. And if a
person is poor, but they have
knowledge, then knowledge is
not considered to be of
significance. And they're
standing in society is
considered to be marginal.
right? And we see this all the
time. Not just with the Muslims
but non Muslims of course and
we take this and we import it
in from non Muslims. We see
this successful celebrity. They
have a net worth of whatever
whatever and so when they speak
20 years old 30 years old, riff
raft off of the street. Haven't
seen a day of of of hardship in
their life. They don't know
anything about the world. They
don't know anything about Allah
and his messenger
but because they have money, we
listen to them.
and we gather for them and we
if we hear that they're coming
to give a speech or a
motivational speech, we clamor
together and we go and we run
and we want to hear what they
have to say. However, it's my
fear that if Imam were
resurrected from his grave
today and were placed in a
stadium, maybe a few hundred
people might show up, maybe and
most of them will leave before
he's finished. Because we have
different scales. This is
exactly what the prophet said
will happen. He said,
The
[Silence]
treacherous and the treacherous
will be deemed as trustworthy
and the foolish will start to
speak on behalf of the masses.
These are the times. He said
also in the narration of he
said
he said every nation will have
something that will spearhead
their fitna. And the fitna of
my wealth, is money
to a person who in Allah's
scales is not worth a dime.
It's not worth a pair of
slippers amongst the amongst
the masses. They will clamor
around him. And a person whom
if he was placed in the scales
of Allah, the mountains of
would not be able to outweigh
him. Nobody has anything to
listen to them for. They
they're not giving it the time
of day. And you can see it. You
see it even on social media.
What what is a better place to
gauge this? Right? Because you
can see likes and dislikes and
views and you see major
scholars of Islam who spent 60,
70 years studying Islam. Have
more knowledge than than have
forgotten more knowledge than
we have ever we will ever hope
to learn. They'll give a
lecture or a speech or a
statement. Maybe two hundred
views. Maybe. Maybe hundred
views but then you have a 17,
eighteen-year-old girl. She'll
put out some three-minute
garble of nonsense with a beat
right? A song and it'll get one
point two, one point three, one
point five billion views. A
sixth of the Earth, listen to
this. the time that we live in
where our scales are are
skewed. We don't see the world
right anymore. We don't see
people as believer and
disbeliever or believer and you
know, strong in faith and weak
in faith. We see people in and
their appearances. He has a
nice car. He has money. He has
this. He has that. We listen
and we come around him and I
said, I want to eat one dude.
Etcetera, etcetera. And we see
this as well in our own country
our leaders that sold us,
literally sold us as slaves to
our enemies If they come, we
all clamor around them and when
they leave, we all speak bad
about them. Isn't this true? We
say, oh, these are terrible
people. They sold us to the,
they sold us to our enemies but
if they come or if they show
up, everybody wants to shake
his hand and get close to him
and I have his number and brag
about it and it's the same
people that sold us. and
scholars of Islam, real
scholars. I'm not talking about
guys with big hats. I'm talking
about real scholars. People
whom the Quran and Sunnah flow
through their blood. If you
were to be able to test it, it
would be in their bone marrow.
These people they are being put
in prison. They are being
marginalized. They are being
attacked. They're being
defamed. They're being
deported. They're being killed
by the masses. Has anybody even
heard about what's happening in
in Bangladesh in the past few
years? In the past four years,
they've they've literally
executed thousands of scholars
of Islam, thousands. Because
they are trying to secularize
the state. Look at it was
what's been going on in Egypt.
Not just now. Not just in the
time of Assisi or for years all
the way since the 50s. This has
been going on. To the point
where a man, a a scholar could
not even grow his beard. You
see, many scholars during that
era, they have no beard. Why?
It's because if you grow a
beard, you get put in prison.
This is what was happening and
it's still happening. And so
the point is is that we're in a
time of extreme fitna. And
we're in a time where our
scales are lopsided. They're
not balanced. We can't see the
world for what it is anymore.
Now we're seeing the world as
money, money, money,
possessions, wealth, you get
the 20 year old, 25 year old.
He's a YouTuber and he's got 25
cars and a $3 million dollar
mansion. And we listen to what
he has to say because he
obviously if he got this, he
must have some kind of wisdom
This is not what the Muslim was
based on. If you would have
seen the companions of the
prophet in their prime, you
would be astounded. They would
walk to battles for months
until their shoes would fall
apart and they would walk
barefoot through the desert to
go to war. three and four
people would ride on a camel, a
single camel, three and four of
them and they would take turns.
If you would to walk into the
prophet Masjid, you would see
men there that were barely,
barely had enough cloth to
cover their own loins. and
those are the men that built
what we have today. Those are
the men why we know about Allah
and his messenger. Those are
those men are the reason.
They're the reason. Those men
and women They gave their
blood. They gave their wealth.
They gave their status. they
gave everything, their soul,
their life in order for Islam
to reach us today. And then we
have people come. They go on
some social media or whatever.
Twenty year old,
thirty-year-old kid, fifty,
sixty, seventy, doesn't know
the first thing about Alif
Batel doesn't know the first
thing about the Quran or how it
is reached us or any discipline
or any serious discipline of
Islam and what happens? They
abuse the work of these men and
women. And they abuse the
legacy of these men and women.
Right? A very good example of
that. Is we want to be Muslim
and we want to be non Muslim at
the same time. We want to have
our cake and eat it at the same
time. You can't. Religion,
Islam is inherently divisive.
You have to choose one path.
You can't be both. Because if
you try to be both, you're
going to be neither. That's the
problem. If you try to be both,
you're going to end up being
neither. and that is what the
hypocrites were in the time of
the prophet he said Allah said
describing them
they are constantly between the
two groups they neither belong
to the non Muslims nor do they
belong to the Muslims
So, we start to have Muslim rap
groups So, they come in wrap
but their wrap is about what?
About the prophet and his
companions. Please if you
want to be a rapper, please
leave the prophet out of it.
Please. Please leave Allah and
the Quran out of it. It has
nothing to do with it. under
the guise of well, we've got to
gather the youth. That's not
how the prophet gathered the
youth. When he became a Muslim,
he was 40 years old when he
became a prophet. And his his
Dawah became widespread in
about seven or eight years
after that. He was on the brink
of 50 years old. And what were
the majority of his followers?
The youth. young people because
the old people were set in
their ways. So, what does a
50-year-old man have to do with
a fourteen and 15-year-old
young man? A lot because he
brought them the truth and
that's what they were looking
for. He didn't start to dress
them and sing songs with
them and try, oh, just gather
around me and you know, I'll
put a, I'll put a drop of honey
in this in this in in your pot
of this is not the way. We have
to be present. We have to have
direction. The scho have to be
different and separate. They
have to be known
and so,
the greatest gift you
can have in these times and I
don't to say the word
uncertain times they are
uncertain times but the word
has been really abused in the
past two, three years because
of the coronavirus. Every
commercial, you know, in these
uncertain times, you know, in
these uncertain times, right?
We've heard it, right? It's in
every commercial but really, we
are in times of darkness. The
prophet said,
Muslim
He said, hasten to do good
deeds
[Silence]
cannot even see it and and and
it will come out and and and
swipe you off of the of the
religion of Allah. Just pull
you right off. He said during
these times, a man may be a
Muslim in the in the in the in
the morning and by night time,
not even eight hours later, he
has renounced his faith.
Doesn't mean that he renounced
all his faith. It means that he
renounced one little bit of his
faith at a time. One sacrifice
here, one here, one here, over
10 years. It's not, it's just a
shell of a Muslim after that.
What did the prophet say the
reason for this would be? He
will sell his religion for
something measly of this world.
Money or status or to be liked
or to be. No, You find your
identity in Allah. And you find
your purpose and direction in
the Quran and Sunnah. Even if
everybody else is not doing
that. Even if the whole tide is
going downstream, you're going
upstream because that's the way
to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
and there was a time when Islam
was easy. It was easy to be
Muslim. Everybody was Muslim.
And if you got out of line,
everyone would put you back in
line. There was a time when the
Quran and the Sunnah, they were
the crown of every Muslim who
walked around. And his dignity
was Islam and his identity as a
Muslim. There was a time like
that. When, in the time Omar
and Ali and and the that came
after them and the and the and
so on and so forth. There were
times even up to the Ottoman
Empire when? Being a Muslim was
a badge of honor. Even amongst
all of humanity. but that
slowly withered away. As the
prophet said it would. Don't be
surprised. Don't be shocked.
Don't be scared. He already
told us this was going to
happen. It's just that we have
to come to realize that it's
happening. and what should I do
when that happens And so the
greatest gift that you can be
given by Allah is that your
heart be open to the Quran and
Sunnah and that you see the
world for what it really is. an
illusion. Yes, it's real. This
is real. I exist. I understand
that. But it's an illusion of,
it's an illusion of pleasure.
It's a brief illusion. Don't
sell your soul. Don't sell your
identity for any part of that
brief illusion.
me hat. Allah said to the
prophet don't be fooled by all
of the travels and lavishness
of those who are are
disbelievers. Don't be fooled
by that. All these caravans and
money and going and come in and
eating fruits in the winter and
going to travel and having
vacations whenever they want
and don't be fooled by that. He
said this to the prophet when
he was in a state where they
were going through famine in
Medina and they're looking at
the disbelievers and it seems
they're flourishing and
the believers because of their
belief, they are being
attacked, confederations are
being formed against them.
they're at constant war,
they're in constant famine,
they're in constant to the
point where the prophet had to
say to the companions,
the meal of one person is
enough for two and the meal of
a of two is enough for three.
He had to say that. This is how
bad things were. And Allah told
him, don't be fooled by what
you see. That's just an
exterior. These people are hell
bound. You're on the right path
even if it doesn't feel like
it. Even if it doesn't look
it. Don't be fooled by
that. Get your, get your scales
right. Money is not everything.
It's important. We need it,
right? We need money. We have
to have money. The masjid that
I'm speaking in. What was built
by? It was built by people of
faith with money. Hamdulillah.
Right? That's not everything.
It's not how we judge people.
That's not how we judge success
A person who is poor, we don't
judge him by his poverty and a
person who a person who is
wealthy, we don't judge him by
his, by his apparent
prosperity. We judge people by
the scales of the Quran and
Sunnah. We let every person
prove to us who they are. They
are good, righteous people, and
they remind us of Allah. I
don't, it doesn't matter if
they don't have, if they, if
they don't even have a home to
live in, if they're homeless.
and if a person has all the
wealth in the world but doesn't
know how to clean himself after
using the restroom properly,
this person is. This person is
obviously not a person that we
should look up to. Right?
People that make us feel good
with their music and their and
their fake smiles and fake
hugs. It doesn't mean anything
to us. People who tell us the
truth even if it hurts, those
are the people that we want to
stick to because we want to
become better. And so the last
and final thing and and and all
of this was said, we're not off
topic here. We are on topic and
why I say we're on topic is
because we have to be able to
see the world for what it
really is and the greatest gift
Allah can give you is light of
faith in your heart. That's the
greatest gift. You can't buy
with all the money in the world
what what amount of money can
pay for a verse of the Quran?
What amount of money? all the
wealth in the earth Billions,
billions, billions, all the
money and all the all of the
the the jets and the leers and
the you know convertibles and
all the limos and all the fancy
money and all of the praise of
everybody. And everybody
looking up to you and gathering
around you to fool you. What
can any of that? If all of it
were to be put together? Can it
pay for one verse of the Quran?
No. It can't pay one verse
and that's why he was
considered to be one of the and
he was one of the greatest of
the earth. He said,
he said, whoever narrates to me
a narration that I don't know,
I will remain his servant for
the rest of my life. I could
never pay him back for that.
How can you pay somebody for
guidance? How can you pay
someone? How can a scholar be
repaid How can a person of
knowledge be repaid? They
taught you. They paved the, how
could we repay the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
How can we repay a and an Imam
Ahmed? How can we repay Sheikh
Al Islam and who are reading
his books now. When he teaches
us the insights of the Quran
and Sunnah. How could we ever
repay him? How? What amount of
money will pay for that? You
can never pay for guidance.
Guidance is something that
Allah gives you and it's
precious. In Muslim, the
prophet said,
in Allah.
He said Allah gives wealth to
those whom he loves and those
whom he does not love. But he
only gives faith to those whom
he loves. That's all that
matters. All the money you see,
what are you going to do? Spend
it all. You have, you have $200
billion dollars. You're
going to spend it all. If you,
if you lived for 25
generations, you with
inflation, you could never
spend all of that money and
guess what? When that person
dies and goes back into the
earth, it goes to someone else
free of charge. It doesn't make
you. What you own does not
define you. What defines you is
your relationship with Allah.
That's where you draw your
value. If you not have that and
you do not have in your heart
and soul. If you don't have on
your soul written the verses of
the Quran and the narrations of
the prophet and the beliefs,
you, what do you own? You own
nothing? You have nothing. and
in a narration which has some
weakness in it, what its
meaning is correct, collected
by
that the prophet was narrated
to have said,
Al Quran he said as heart that
has no Quran in it, is a
broken down house. It's
useless.
right? So, the final thing that
Ibn il Kayah mentions with
regards to the things that open
the heart He says,
known. He says, the final thing
that we can do to try to open
our hearts to the faith, to the
light, is leaving off that
which is unnecessary of what we
see, what we say, what we
listen to, those whom we
congregate with, that which we
eat, and the amount of time we
sleep. So, notice here his
wording
is to leave off that which is
that which is above what is
necessary of what you look at,
what you say, what you listen
to, whom you gather with and
congregate with, what you eat,
and the amount of time that you
sleep.
So anything more than what you
need of these things, they are
a hindrance. They become an
illness, a disease. The more
you sit with people that have
nothing to say about Allah and
his messenger, the more your
heart will be filled with dust
and smoke Ibn ul Kaim said
in another book of his
The more you eat, more than you
need to, the more this becomes
a disease. The more you lay
around and sleep, more than you
need to to have the energy to
get up and face the day, the
more this causes and becomes a
disease in your heart. The more
you look and pay attention to
things that don't deserve your
attention.
Looking at things that are
unnecessary. Whether that is
reading things that are
unnecessary. Let alone those
things which are haram. He's
not speaking about what is
haram. He's speaking about what
is extra, what is unnecessary.
we have a hunger as human
beings naturally for knowledge
and information We have a
natural hunger for knowledge
and information and knowledge
and information, if it is taken
in too quickly, it's just like
eating too much food. It will
be turned into fat and it will
eventually kill you. It has to
be digested, taken in slowly,
and you have to vet what it is
you eat, what it is you learn.
So, this is the final thing
that Ibn il Kaim mentions I'll
repeat it and then we'll listen
to the Adan. He says, leaving
off that which is unnecessary
of what we look at, what we
say, what we listen to, whom we
congregate with, what we eat,
and the amount of time that we
sleep Next week inshallah, we
will move on to the way the
prophet used to exercise
fasting.
Muhammad thank you